so you can see on the board and some of
you are this sure alarm bells for you
right you can see on the board I'm going
to show you two different ways to work
out this correlation coefficient one of
them is really without a calculator
and that's why I've handed you this
piece of paper okay to do this you need
to know the formula for this which
you'll find in the exercise book and you
have to do it by hand it's quite a
laborious process now very deliberately
the syllabus actually doesn't say you
need to know the formula and be able to
do it by hand what they do say is you
need to be able to use technology I'll
show you how to do it with a with a
spreadsheet with a calculator that's
what they say you have to be able to do
just four I come to a question the
danger of course is if all you know is
how to crunch numbers and put them into
a black box and out you know arises some
number if you don't understand where
that came from
then you're kind of not really being a
mathematician you're just being a
machine so we're not going to do this
very often in fact we're probably only
going to do this once but it's so that
when you go to your calculator you know
what on earth it's doing well you can
ask question ah
I've actually pinched one of yours mrs.
Lee's so hopefully isn't as bad okay
good so you will need your calculator
for this next part we're going to do it
manually first coach the numbers and
then I'm going to show you how to
actually get your calculator to do it
all automatically for you okay now you
can see I'm just going to find the right
spot if you go to the end go past
exercise to flick forward a few pages
and you'll come to a page that looks
like this I have to describe like that
because I have two page numbers sorry I
keep on anyway so you'll see up the top
it says our formula for Pearson's
coefficient that's what I'm about to
show you now this is really important
this formula here I want us to write it
down you can see that are there that I
referred to perform so it says R equals
and then there's this monstrous thing
that we're going to unpack together okay
so it's a fraction the start is what's
on the numerator well you recognize this
Greek symbol I
what's the name of this Greek symbol
Sigma and what is it refer to what does
it do max sale again it's the sum of a
bunch of different things rs4 some okay
then you'll see and we'll write this
down together some things in brackets
here okay it says X minus X bar times y
minus y bar that's the way we say it
this is stretching a little bit but does
anyone remember has anyone seen this
notation before X bar you might have
seen it in other subjects actually more
what have you seen it's the mean of X
and the mean of Y okay if that's
something you've not encountered before
maybe you want to just drop that down
for yourself because it is actually
fairly common notation to use the full
name that we learnt a few weeks back to
the arithmetic mean so just the average
you know what that's about that's the
numerator okay and then you've got the
denominator which is even grosser so
there's a gigantic square root sign okay
and then underneath the square root
there's a couple more of these Sigma's
it's X minus X bar squared and then
another Sigma Y minus y bar squared my
goodness what is this mess okay let's
think about what this means X & Y these
are scores right it's like oh how many
how many police were on duty how many
incidences of crime did we report okay
what we're doing here when we go and say
take away X sorry the other way around
take X and then subtract X bar what
we're doing is we're working out the
difference between that particular
instance that particular night in the
precinct and we're comparing it to the
average right
is this more than we get on average is a
less than we get on average and we do
the same for number of police okay so
what you're getting here is a bunch of
differences now I hope this rings bell
when you think back to standard
deviation and variance this is the idea
it's like how far are you away from an
average not from an average person okay
what's the distance what you've got down
here we'll come to that as we start to
calculate it so here is a data set
okay now I've deliberately picked a
relatively small quantity of numbers and
I've tried to keep the numbers nice and
easy we'll even get some whole numbers
out of this so that the calculation is
not what you're focused on it's so that
you can actually figure out what it's
doing okay so for starters to work out
our numerator our X take away X bar Y
take away Y bar you can see HX and hy
has its own one I need to know what X
bar and y bar I need to know what those
averages are so go ahead I've given you
five scores so for each one maybe with
the person next to you you need to add
up your X scores and divide by how many
scores error which in this case is five
then you need to add up your Y scores
and then divide them also by five so
when someone gets X bar can they share
with us do we get nine excellent and why
byes in the 20s right 22 thank you okay
now that we've got an X bar and y bar we
can really quickly it's just some simple
number crunching we can work out each of
these differences I'll give you the
first one for free X minus X bar on the
first row is 6 let me highlight it for
you 6 there's X take away 9 there's X
bar so 6 take away 9 what's that
negative 3 thank you very much okay and
then we're going to keep on just going
down the line right 7 take away 9 that's
the new X take away X bar that's gonna
be negative 2 7 take away 9 9 take away
9 0 and you can keep on going now I get
positives 10 taker oh sorry
10 take away 9 and then 13 take away 9
okay so there are my X minus X bar
values and you can do the same for the Y
bar values Y minus y bar first ones 15
takeaway 22 which is negative 7 and then
you can carry on from there yeah
you're talking about here ah
now you'll see in a second why I'm
actually not it's you can see I've got
all these gray ones where we're gonna
put some totals and I'm not gonna put
titles there and I'll show you why in a
second let's just get the numbers first
okay good question though
do numbers check out does that look okay
to you Pappy I just did them in my head
all right now have a look back to our
formula for the Pearson correlation
coefficient on the numerator it says I
want you to add up a bunch of things
what things doesn't want us to add look
closely yeah
we're adding a bunch of things what
things are we adding I'll admit the
notation isn't the clearest but you can
see we just worked out a whole column of
X take away X bars and a whole column of
Y take away Y bars what's the operation
kind of hiding in here that we don't
write it's multiplication right so it
says take that product take that product
you'll get a product here and a poet
here and a product here and then once
you've got all these products what are
you gonna do with all of them you're
gonna add those up okay does that make
sense so individually I don't really
care about what these add up see that's
why I've left this blank individually I
don't care what the Y minus y bar I care
about what happens when I multiply them
together okay so go ahead negative 3 and
take away or multiply by negative 7 I
should say come we can just do this out
loud right negative 3 times negative 7
21 thank you negative 2 times negative 3
6 0 times 1 0 1 times 4 and then the
last one is okay excellent so now I've
got these 5 values these are the things
that I'm adding up 21 6 4 and 20 that
looks to me using my friends of 10 like
51 51 happy ok excellent so just before
we go any further what have we just
worked out we just worked out this thing
this whole numerator in our case here in
our example it's 51 that's just what we
got okay but then we move on to the
denominator which is a bit of a mess
thankfully we've actually done most of
the work okay you can see we're going to
take the square root of these things all
added up together this is the X take
where X bar is squared and then these
things all added up together so that's
why you can see down the bottom
here we're going to get each of our
independent values can I just hit pause
and let you guys work out what is each
of this these values here's X take away
X bar so square it and you'll get a new
number square it you'll get a new number
and so on okay that'll fill in this
second last column and then you're going
to square all these guys that'll give
you a last comment can I give you a
second to work those out yeah